Ulu
Tanrımız
Ben de var namazı Sokaklar Say basınca
Anne bir sebebiyle uzun süredir Hasret
kaldığımız görüntüler Aslında böyle
konuşmaya başlasam düşünür ve
az insan varken çalışmayı tercih
ediyorum
Çünkü o
[Müzik]
Evet aynen öyle çok daha insanlar şekeri
şeylerden bahsediyorlar
ümitsizlik üzerine
ve aslında bana hoşuma gitti Çünkü
boyarken çok duyduğum olur
Ben çok Vallahi daha
ne kadar zor olabilir ki diye
düşünüyorum ya Doğan ve ikinci el
Bu ikisi yan kadar geçeceksin Keşke ben
de
yıkandığı için göremiyorum
Allah Allah söyleyeceğim
çizim yapmak ne zaman başladı çocuklukta
hatırlatıp
çocuklar geliyor galiba diye bir şey
soruyorum mutlaka çocuklarda çok
incelikli olmalısın ki büyüyünce böyle
şeyler çözebilirsiniz
evet çocuklar o
[Müzik]
o balonu yazdım Bazı oradan dinozorun
vücudunu istediği kuşun kafasını bir
şeyi kuyruğunu bir şey kanatlarımız
birleştirip farklı bir hayvan sıvıyağı
sonra acımız buna bakıp
Beklerken o
[Müzik]
Sen
neden olmadın Aslında kendimi yeteneksiz
diye düşündüm belki çocuk psikolojisi
değil mi o orada lazım yanında eğitimin
önemine
izni alakalı yerde söylemek daha
doğrudur
O da ağzında güzel sabahtan da olacağım
bir arkadaşımla muhabbet ederken
söylediğin konuşacağız altından geçiyor
Tamam onları çizimi Ben de kullanmış
değil
o da nereden biliyorsunuz dedim o dedi o
da anlattım o da çok saçma bir şey
durumu yani bundan çizmek o
[Müzik]
bu fakat dördüncü galiba şey yazacağım
bir şey çizdim Yani ben de geliyorum
başlamıştım
etti ve Yaptığım şeyleri arkadaşlarına
göster
arkadaşlarla buluştuğumuz o
bir arkadaşından da çok kocaman gördüm
seçiyorum aslında yani alınan
bırakıldı
konusu çocuklukta büyüdü arkadaşlardan
oluyorum dedim ya herhalde gerçekten ya
da bu başka bir şey sonra mesleklerle
alakalı bir
arkadaşıma konuştu incelediler yaptığım
hataları gösterdi ya
mı
koyuyorlar Aslında
bunu sarılı psikolojik olarak bilmiyorum
herkesi yapamadığı bir şeyi
Sizinde yapmamızı istiyor Nedenini
bilmiyorum
bir şey
burada emin olduğum şey resim çizemem
ama bir şey yapamam ki
bu
devam ediyor ayrıca
güzel sanatları Burası kokusu da tadı
yeter hazırlıyordu
orada
uzun
çünkü de o
[Müzik]
bu
sonra ve
Aslında iki Elif Ey sevgili sonunda
Sizin yapabilirim farkettim yani
kendime Eskiden uygun değil mi Artık
geçersiz olduğundan Sonra
şöyle bir şeye dönüşür O zaman bu
sefer w52h
[Müzik]
bu sonra Odunpazarı önünde uzun
pazarının oradaki gece Bunlar varken
Daha doğrusu orada ceza buz altında ve
ben Sokak sandığı yazılmıştır
zaten Bazen o
[Müzik]
bu sonuç olarak bu sefer duvar konusunda
ebatı büyütmeye başladı Yani de
Evet şu anda numara görünce
heyecanlanmaya başladım O birazcık daha
heyecanlanmamak için ne yapalım Demir
sorguları daha büyük daha daha daha
Allah yuvarlanıyor öğrenmeye başladım
Fakat bu kadar sınır olayı sizden
çıkıyor Çünkü Siz kendinizi
daha numara vermek istiyorsunuz o
de böyle bir Aslında sınırlı yolculuğu
Bu
resim yapmaya
başlasam dair çok da çocuk değil
yani Kafamızda Eğer
ya yetenek çocuk öncelerde şey varsa
çocuklar
Her şey bu 11i
[Müzik]
Bu bir bakıyorum var mı Yani biraz daha
önce var mı veya daha sonra lan herhangi
bölümü yapacağım lan şey
bir şeyi yapmayı ne kadar sevdiğiniz
seviyorsanız da geçmiş bölüm kalmadı
aşkım yanlış hatırlıyorum
O başka
[ __ ]
uzun mu o
[Alkış]